in North Korea they said this morning
that it is aiming to reach an
equilibrium of military force with the
United States North Korean leader Kim
jong-un watched as the North fired yet
another missile Friday it landed in the
Pacific Ocean this comes as President
Trump is preparing to give his first
address to the United Nations next week
Aaron Barnett is traveling with the
president in New Jersey
Erol good morning good morning as a
presidential candidate Donald Trump
denounced the UN as incompetent and
threatened to cut US taxpayer funds but
as president he says the international
body has potential and in his speech on
Tuesday is expected to outline a map to
tackle global issues like the North
Korean nuclear threat we will defend our
people our nations and our civilization
from all who dare to threaten our way of
life this includes the regime of North
Korea days before his speech to the UN
President Trump stood before stealth
aircraft and the US Air Force to send a
signal to North Korea our options in
addressing this threat are both
effective and overwhelming the latest
missile launch occurred three days after
the UN Security Council enacted new
sanctions against Pyongyang it's North
Korea remains one of the world's most
urgent and dangerous security problems
National Security Adviser HR McMaster
said Friday the time to address the
global threat is running out we've been
kicking the can down the road and we're
out of Road the President's speech
Tuesday at the UN General Assembly will
feature similar warnings against the
rogue regime
as well as assurances to American allies
I personally think he slaps the right
people he hugs the right people and he
comes out with us being very strong in
the end previewing next week's speech US
ambassador to the UN nikki Haley said
the US aims to promote peace and
prosperity during the meeting of some
120 nations the utter weakness and
incompetence of the United Nations it's
a landmark moment for a
commander-in-chief who railed against
the global body during the campaign the
United Nations is not a friend of
democracy it's not a friend to freedom
it's not a friend even to the United
States of America but the president's
America first agenda is unlikely to be
met with cheers at the General Assembly
on Friday Haley said the world would
have to wait and see whether president
Trump would commit the u.s. to funding
the UN at current levels I think the
president has always believed there's
great potential in the United Nations
now another topic the president may
discuss is the u.s. commitment to the
Iran nuclear deal already president
Trump has called it the worst deal ever
and there is international concern he
may find Iran in violation of the deal
next month the first hints of that could
come in Tuesday speech Anthony Cheryl
Barnett thanks Errol